listen I really want to start with I
love the show uh great season uh I have
a ton of questions but for both of you
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why oh Stephen great question I uh I
think I I I I think it might be the
thing that got me cast on upload so I
would definitely want people to watch uh
my standup because I'm a stand-up
comedian um and I I would want them to
watch that first but I I I would have to
say that upload is definitely a strong
runner up like I feel like people really
love and support the character Alicia so
I'm I'm really proud to play her this is
maybe this is maybe a little out there
but I my career started on a competition
dance series called So You Think You Can
Dance and I I think I've gotten I spent
so many years trying to uh you know
bridge the gap into into acting and
being taken seriously as an actor and
and now I'm at this place where I have
to remind people that that's where I
started and uh I'm very proud of it and
I think I would have never thought my
career would have started in that way
but I love where I'm at and I'm so
grateful for it so I hope people would
start with that with that understanding
of me and my work and and um where I've
come from it like informs where you are
now and I'm going to agree with Zena
that in second place I want them to
watch season three of
upload when when when Janine was first
cast Allegra who plays Ingrid you know
she was
like I love J and I was like oh how do
you know and she was like oh have you
seen her dancing have you SE like I mean
Allegra would not right and then when as
soon as we were on set together I was
like algra I have a
surprise that was the best she's so
sweet
love her love her speaking of upload
season 3 uh when you think back on the
filming of the Season uh what is what
what was the day that you had circled in
terms of you were really excited to film
it or you were really nervous to film it
oh that's very easy for me upload season
3 um you know this is a spoiler for
anybody who has oh yeah we're doing
spoilers oh for sure we're doing
spoilers um uh I know that it's out
already but so everybody watch um but
definitely like I there's a scene where
there's assumed um intimacy between
Alicia and Karina um and uh Alicia and
Karina kiss and that was that was
nervous I was very very nervous um uh
yeah and I remember
just I don't know you become a Ware of
so many things like what do I look like
when I kiss you know what I'm saying
like what you just think of things that
you would have never I wish I wish that
the thought was like oh my God like I'm
so nervous to kiss a girl or I'm so
think I just thought
like what like do what chapstick do I
wear that day you know like just like
just ridiculous stuff I just remember
that was like you know the the other
characters I had seen them working with
the the intimacy coordinators and things
like that in Seasons prior and I knew
that this was the mo you know we even
some scenes I can't remember what was
cut or not but we had to be in you know
assumed nudity and I just that was all
very new for me um and so those those
were probably my most nervous moments on
set this season I'm a fan of upload
before I got to be on the show and I'm
fan of zanab and um more so now even
since I I just went to the taping of her
comedy special in Harlem with one of my
good friends and she's a goddess and in
um in in real life she is a goddess as
much as she is on the screen and I was
so nervous that first day because uh
she's just got such a a a profoundly
honest and grounded and uh calm energy
and I wanted to really attempt to to to
to match her where she is so
effortlessly and uh so I was nervous I
was it's it's it's nerve-wracking to be
in a new character on a new set always
but uh she is such a presence I was so
nervous at first day and when I watch
those scenes back from our first episode
I see my nervousness really doesn't I
you know how you're just like you can't
fool yourself you know and uh but she
she made it so comfortable and and
inviting it was lovely yeah one of the
things I I think resonates with people
about upload is that you I think that at
some point in the future some form of
this is going to be possible you know
not this exact version but you know some
version so if you had the option I know
you've probably been asked this before
but if you have the option of doing
something like this would you actually
do
it we yeah this is a a very common
question and why wouldn't it be right I
mean it's it is a deep it it is a deep
question and I I believe at some point
we probably will yeah you know be faced
with that um I've always said no I've
always said no because you know I'm also
coming from the remember Alicia lost Dr
Caputo in season one you know so I'm
always like I'mma get somebody like
Alicia and you know um so I I I
typically say no
but I don't know something about season
3 you know there's this ability to
upload download there's you know um and
I I I I still don't know but I'm
definitely moving away from the absolute
no sure you know I gotta think no as
well uh I'm sure in reality I I'd
explore the option but I don't know I'm
kind of curious about what's next and I
wouldn't want to I wouldn't want to lose
the opportunity to explore that too sure
that's totally valid um uh so I curious
and this is going to be obviously a
spoiler question but um what did you
both think about the season 3 finale and
where it all went okay so before the the
public got it um and and Janine couldn't
be a part of this because you know she's
not in LA but Greg had most of the cast
over to his theater and sounds
so he's Greg he's Greg um he had us over
to and we watched and we watched in the
way that we knew it would be released so
we watched every two episodes and then
we took a break and we got food and we
chatted and this was like a whole day
thing and I remember the
finale I was like I couldn't take it I
was laid out in the theater and I I I
couldn't take it and I also for the
first time didn't know which Nathan I
wanted I didn't know if I wanted real
life Nathan or backup Nathan I didn't
know who I wanted to serve as Nora or
ingred I I mean yeah I was just like as
much as I knew what was coming I still
was in awe and disbelief 100% I just
watched it z i I meant to text you
because I just the first time I read it
you know it's a it's an interesting
thing being a an actor where you get to
you see it on the page first and it
shocked me to my core but I I didn't
know where my all my allegiance was this
time I completely agree with you and
algra like ing's Evolution I did not
expect her to win me over as much as she
did where I am devastated if it's not
her Nathan but then you know Nora is my
girl like it's like it's so complicated
then it then it poses the idea right
because if we think about it right
Stephen it's like um we all have like
let's say celebrity crushes right and
it's like yeah my celebrity crush is
married but like if there was this if
there was a way in the world where I
could also have this person and then and
then they you you know like that's
that's like interesting but also scary I
found myself like well I mean can't we
keep up can't we keep like reboot n you
know like upload Nation I'm Nation
Nathan and you know you know and back up
Nathan like can't we just have both of
them you know so even just thinking
about that in the real real world is
kind
of I don't know scary to imagine 100%
yeah that but that's also I also feel
agree with you uh that uh I don't the
because the writing is so good it makes
you care and that's why we're all like
well what Nathan is it you know so
anyway listen I got to stop I'm just
going to say really enjoyed your work uh
in upload season 3 and uh anyway you
guys have a fantastic day and uh good
luck with the rest of your viewer speed
dating thank
you